this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbuster
summer
from peak spielberg comes a masterpiece
of visual filmmaking
that works on every possible level to
create an all-time classic fill
[Music]
hey stay focused that was for mac and me
e.t the extraterrestrial get on your
bikes and ride for one of the most
uplifting stories ever told about a
co-dependent relationship
where a stranded alien stalks a child
forges a physical emotional link without
his consent
[Music]
and puts him through unfathomable pain
unless he helps him go home
he needs to go to be fair
he's not as bad as the mac and me aliens
those things are just monsters
[Music]
sorry just can't stop thinking about
making me movie really sticks with you
follow along with this ugly old wrinkly
trashcan looking ass alien
that pulls off the impossible trick of
making you love him despite his horrible
face
and disgustingly long salad fingers then
once you learn to look past all that
and open your heart watch him slowly die
and i mean die die like put him in a
baghdad
the only thing that could have been more
of a gut punch is that they killed his
entire family
[Music]
this is what i see when i close my eyes
at night
enjoy this simple film told with such
detail craft and subtlety
it's become an iconic text about
childhood and while mac and me is also
about a stranded alien who prevents a
child with a name that starts with e who
lives in california with a hard-working
single mother and an older brother named
michael who's lured out of hiding by a
trail of snacks left by a boy who takes
home sick from school and when the
government is on his tail they dress him
up in a costume leading agents to chase
the kid through the neighborhood but the
mom sells them out then the kid almost
dies until the alien heals him the
difference is
e.t is good
while only making me has an eight-minute
long dance sequence in a mcdonald's
your hero is in a wheelchair why would
you do this
so whether you want a children's fantasy
come to life in a groundbreaking work of
movie magic
or the movie equivalent of your mom
buying you the wrong toy for christmas
the film that gave us the breakout role
for drew barrymore or the first role of
jennifer aniston
guys i'm not lying is that her i think
check out either the film that should
have won best picture that year
or the film that had a profit sharing
agreement with the charity but flopped
so hard they couldn't pay them a cent
no no you will not starring
homophone drew barrymore
representation for the disabled
community misrepresentation of native
americans
keys keys keys keys on bad guys how to
disguise your stuntmen
[Music]
botanicus is that you a literal
fleshlight
five nights at freddy's maroon with
children
a wrinkle and slime and fetus the
slack-jawed yokel
awkward tween hunger force
[Music]
sorry we kind of bait and switched you
with this one but e.t is pretty much
flawless
here we'll leave you with a deleted
ant-man see from avengers in-game cool
[Music]
got things to say about stuff fanlet
wants to hear your opinions on
all things gaming and entertainment in
exchange for chances at cool rewards and
prizes
click the box or the link in the
description to see if you qualify
and he lived happily ever after to the
end of his days
choose your destiny